qualcuno atto sito ho sentito tossire
meglio che carico l'arma dove ti
nascondi è qui in questa stanza non
farmi scoprire nuovi episodi di netto di
nuovo gas ma questa volta però una
codino che il tuo colore
io oggi sono team viola io per the line
come gli episodi dovremmo pescare dal
calderone il nostro ruolo che potrebbe
essere offrì merito impostore c'è anche
merlino poi avremo girare la ruota per
decidere il colore in cui andremo a
nascondersi perché potremmo giappone si
sono messe nel colore che fu rapita
nella ruota è anche un altra aggiunta
questa volta cioè chi vince il turno
potrà aprire una delle
per i big perché questa volta che li
pizzi vincerà realmente un premio dovrà
aprire una busta misteriosa che contiene
un premio misteriosa poi ovviamente
lasciate subito un mi piace e durante
questo video avrete delle tasche anche
voi eh sì
indossiamo con la vostra prima tac la
vostra prima tasche la sera mi piace
entro 5 secondi pronto a fare due
notebook caduto in terra ma ora iniziamo
subito per il primo turno perché non
vedo l'ora di scoprire che sorprese ci
sono dentro anch'io spero che ci sia
qualcosa di mangiare a casa è bello solo
per berlino iniziamo subito con il primo
era un primo possiamo scegliere tra i
nostri capelli proprio come in among us
allora vediamo secondo me quale mi sto
meglio votate nei commenti mi sta qui
di fatto di fiori il mio preferito è
l'acqua abbiamo berlino come reagisce
basta non ne aree berlino berlino e un
po scioccato già vecchio team e genito
questo se gli allora vediamo posso
prendere o questo da bicicletta mi sta
bene che scenderò il viso preferito mio
preferito è questo il vaso di fiori
meglio si sé non so perché ma vitale
allora quel fratello abbiamo loro d'ora
e sito preferito in assoluto
ok tu avrai quello che grazie ti piace
quello che quindi questo è quello che
hai scelto mezzi e viola come il mio
outfit ok ok è questa ok molto meglio
così dire sempre questo le orecchie
ma andiamo a pescare i nostri ruoli by
giallo tocca a te backup crediamo già
peccato vediamo lascia
[Applauso]
ok tocca me adesso
bene ora devi girare la ruota per vedere
in quale colore dovrei nascondermi peace
blu bene allora io vado di là in
corridoio inizia a contare una questo
che faccio sono state qualcosa di blu
fee
[Musica]
e blu blu e blu non vuol dire niente io
mi nascondo qui caduta 8 arrivando
cercare crew metto in qualcosa di blu ho
dimenticato di scegliere l'arma allora
devo tornare in cameretta e scegliere
l'arma eccoci qua eh eh eh ma tu non ti
sei nascosto gialloni nascosto
ricevo dirmi qualcosa e poi qua guardi
fuori stai guardando fuori ho capito
allora giallo sta guardando fuori quindi
vuol dire che verde si è nascosto fuori
in giardino e giallo mi dà sempre molti
indizi comunque che arma scelgo questa
mi dispiace già aveva trovato quindi più
presto giallo ha perso questo turno ma
ora andiamo a prendere verde che
sicuramente poi in giardino a ok ragazzi
siamo in giardino
vediamo dove si è nascosto verde per
forse essersi nascosto in qualcosa di
blu
l'ho beccato
ma andiamo subito a prenderlo
[Musica]
quindi ora aprirò molto nettamente la
tenda guardate l'impostore a vita ora
posso scegliere la mistery bag da aprire
un secolo mystery bag gialla sveliamo
dentro la magari ci sono i croccantini
di giallo nel posto nella busta gialla
no non mi sembra ridicola questa volta
non c'è la busta verde e di plastica e
un apparente di trucchi progetto si
mangiano 9 dic e di plastica nero sul
bellissimo questo primo premio spero di
vincere crea altre mystery bag spero che
ci sia altro cibo della distribuzione
altro cibo febbre wright e va a mangiare
sempre più corta berlino tu sarai un
tutto chi questa volta sarò cattivissimo
cattivissimo viti questo vuol dire che
tu sarai più bei rosa non ci fa tenere
premuto accordo va bene ok inizia a
contare vai pure nel corridoio
siete pronti entrambi ok allora se siete
pronti io inizio a contare ora 23 47 14
18 ognuno in suv nascono dormirò per un
saluto
un'idea o una coperta rossa o questa
coperta rosa però se mi metto
semplicemente sotto la coperta lui mi
vedranno devo nascondermi dentro
qualcosa e magari mettere sopra la
coperta mi è venuta un'idea geniale
guardate anche i ragazzi proverò a
nascondermi qua dentro
e poi metterò la coperta rossa sopra
così il colore sarà rosa
il problema è che non so se ci sto qua
dentro probabilmente no
eppure ci provo lo stesso sarà molto
divertente no è arrivato già non mi
vuole rubare il nascondiglio ma che
mangiano e va bene giallo vai tu guarda
ok ok giallo ha deciso di stare solo qua
a controllare il mio nascondiglio ora
provando a stendervi spero che sarà un
po dentro giallo mi raccomando tu non
devi tirare in parte sono nascosta qua
ok
sono nascosta abbastanza bene sì devo
dire che non so perché non si sta molto
bene nascosti qua rilassante stare qua
mi ascolti poi mi troverei acqua
questa volta credo che sceglierò il cnel
ok merlino mi dispiace voti ho già preso
quindi hai perso qualcuno atto sito
ho sentito tossire al meglio che carico
lar là dove ti nascondi è qui in questa
stanza
sembra che questi rumori provengono da
lì guardate un po anche una coperta rosa
li vediamo che cosa succede
sembra non ci sia nascosto nessuno lo
bello
qualcosa mi dice che se magari io mi
siedo qui c'è qualcuno
mi hai trovato
sì sì perché perché sono troppo
intelligente no non è vero perché non
tanto si fa ha vinto l'import ore in
verde che mister ebay selling era ora
non vedo l'ora
allora io prima ho sentito l'odore di
cibo quindi lascerò scegliere il mio
naso
hai sentito odore di cibo da questa
pista e beck perche tutte se qualcosa
abbiamo un po disney mangiare ha detto
mistery box mi ha solo saggio è un'altra
tusk per voi scrivete nei commenti che
colora scegliete voi solitamente quando
giocate da mon gas
scrivete lo zoom nei commenti si chiama
che a me quindi in tutto reggiano
giriamo la ruota per scoprire in che
color dobbiamo lottare
verde giardino il giardino e spero di
potermi l'erba gli alberi toma e tutto
verde
ok siamo in giardino e tutto verde
potremmo nascondersi dove vogliamo però
ci troverebbe subito giallo merlino se
ci nascondiamo qua nell'erba oppure se
avete visto l'episodio di precedenti
sapete che ho provato a nascondervi
sotto all'erba finta ma mi ha trovato lo
stesso qui e ho avuto un'idea proverò a
nascondervi sopra ad un albero e un po
strano non so neanche se ci riesco ad
arrampicarmi ma ci provo
cerchiamo un albero giusto e cosa avevo
in a fondere mi nasconderò dietro un
cespuglio credo così almeno non mi
trovano sicuro di questi tipo là dietro
[Musica]
ho trovato questo mio nascondino
o no
in casa viola è stato preso meglio che
mi nascondo qua sotto
oh no ono si sta avvicinando giorno è
arrivato
l'impostore giallo ha vinto però mitri
back di giallo che sociale ecco perché
sgranocchiare effetti giallo non è molto
prova a nascondersi da crema da
impostore è imbattibile però perso fiuto
chi scopre sempre questo amore a lui
peccato
quindi io già l'ho io e merlino saremo
crionet andiamo a girare a ruota vediamo
che colore giocate qualcosa di celeste
allora io sceglierò l'arma la mia
preferita
iniziamo da 123 a domandare ok vediamo
dopo ci sbrighiamo dobbiamo trovare
qualcosa di celeste in cui nascondersi
in armadio e giaretta ed è anche enorme
quindi penso di starci dentro perché
l'impostore non mi troverà subito però
mario presta a venire con me nasconderti
dietro l'armadio c'è abbastanza sua già
mondo sono sconti estivi a qualche altra
parte versione mi già in arrivo alla
ricerca di viola e giallo
credo di aver già trovato giallo
nasconde dietro giallo purtroppo verde e
giallo io ho trovato hai perso trovato
merlino che ci fai
stai annusando il cibo e del cibo qua
dentro
no no no no no non farmi scoprire nel
frattempo noi andiamo a cercare viola
dove sarà forse si nasconde dietro la
scrivania e qua dietro quindi magari fa
dentro allora ha detto qua no
magari viola ha lasciato questa stanza
forse la devo andare a cercare da
un'altra parte ninja verde all'attacco
via ragazzi l'impostore andato a
un'altra stanza sbrighiamoci siamo
dall'armadio mtv la targhetta crew matt
nel calderone così a propri tutor
montiamo via libera target a crew weight
anzi preso anche quella di berlino ecco
qua mettiamo entrambe le targhette nel
calderone
avventa non sei riuscita a trovarmi e
non si dicono anche dove non accolta
perché mentre lo appoggiava si dovrebbe
tenerla uomo da dentro
hai visto giallo abbiamo vinto anche se
tu sei stato trovato ma va comunque
metta la sua targhetta di calderon e
abbiamo vinto vediamo che succede in
questa bisturi bag allora abbiamo un
un extension e colorata che bello quella
che i colori la prova subito con listen
proviamo la sua vitale è sconvolto da
questa cosa è scioccata berlino che
ripensi berlino sta bene evitare con
extension
poi abbiamo iniziato rie no perché sono
nero e grigio no sembra non vedevi di
iniziare in realtà sono per il trucco
non gli bastava degli evidenziatori però
mai catalogo non è un evidenziatore come
può un evidenziatore essere nero disegno
call call state
mi sa che tutto storto sorpresa non c'è
un altro colore e tipo rosa vaio tu hai
fatto il cerchio poi l'ultima cosa
harry potter è un poco botto misterioso
un personaggino misterioso dentro questo
globo di vetro andiamo a vedere chi ci
capita spero che mi capiti o hermione
hermione con il vestito rosa che bella
oppure anche la fenice ma anche del
silente
vediamo vediamo chi è che lo dice
guardate che carino il giudice la droga
rete che bello con dentro ultima tusk
per voi scriveteci nei commenti quale
delle mystery back mi è piaciuta di più
e ora cliccate su una di queste quattro
per dire ovviamente lasciate un mi piace
se volete vedere un'altra nascondino
among us con le sorprese cliccate qui
[Applauso]